Patriots have wanted to and like I said
I'm wondering what it could this be any
different than years before by that I
mean that they usually right the ship
I think Edelman comes back and makes
this a better offense and makes a the
playmakers more available that he
currently has I'm talking about Brady
maybe Josh Gordon does something or
maybe what's in this book Bella check
shows you that certain things might not
be so hunky-dory within that building
regardless of the winning and if the
winning doesn't happen and that
deodorant doesn't get applied maybe
something happens to the Patriots this
year that often than not and the author
Ian O'Connor joining me here on the show
congrats on the book and thank you rich
how are you I am great thank you what's
been the reception on this book from it
officially comes out tomorrow yeah but I
did send advance copies to Belichick and
and and Kraft and the rest up there I
have not heard any word from the
Patriots on it so I don't know what they
feel about it and but I do know people
who've read the manuscript and advanced
copies and the reaction I got for the
most part was I like Bill more after
reading it than I did before so I tried
to make it a humanizing portrait of the
man and and show that side of him that
he never shows in public but it's not
easy to humanize someone who doesn't
want to be humanized in public and by
interviewing hundreds of people I tried
to do that and I guess the reader will
decide whether or not I succeeded so
what's the answer to the question why
does Bella check not want to be
humanized in public like most humans
would probably want yeah right most
celebrities they want to show their best
side in public and hide their worst side
in private Belichick does the reverse or
the head I don't but I think it's all
about he sets that organizational tone
with every press confidence and that is
it revolves around the idea of give them
nothing more than is absolutely
necessary we are in the business of
collecting information not sharing it
and by setting that tone he wants the
players to see that and act accordingly
in the locker room when they're asked
questions by the media give nothing away
he is the greatest net taker of
information of all time and that
involves every conversation about
football he's ever had with anybody he
wants to walk away with more than he
gives so I think it's more about that
than anything else but in talking to
some of his friends who didn't want to
be named some of them do
wish that he would show some humanity at
the podium because away from the
facility bill can be charming he's
engaging he could be funny he's a lot of
things generous that the Irish football
fan outside of New England around the
country would not believe no I mean
because I have been on the receiving end
of that generosity Ian I was calling you
know doing the action calling action
however you want to put a play-by-play
of the combine this year talking about
you know how my my 40-yard dash and my
suit running for st. Jude Children's
yeah you know research and all of a
sudden over my left shoulder comes an
arm slapping a personal check on my
notes and I looked up over my left and
shoulder and there was a smiling Bill
Belichick at me I'm not gonna say how
much it was but it was absurdly generous
a personal check from from Stephen
Belichick and you know it was I mean
from from Bill Belichick and it was
something else
Ian why doesn't he want that sort of
stuff out there and I was watching when
that happened by the way and you know
the other thing is that people say he
hates the media he doesn't hate the
media I know he respects you and I he
respects a number of people in the
profession he sent holiday cards to
certain people and again I think it goes
back to when I'm at work I'm work bill
and I have no interest in the public
knowing that I'm actually a pretty damn
good human being away from the office my
only mission when I'm on site is to help
my team win football games and I really
don't care what you think of work bill
my friends no human bill away from
Patriot place and that's good enough for
me so I guess there's a certain honor in
that because I've been talking to
friends really well I'd love to tell you
all these great stories positive stories
and anecdotes about Bill but I'm afraid
he's gonna get mad at me and I said well
if you don't tell those stories they're
never gonna get out there and don't you
want him to be seen as completely human
and so it's a it's a fascinating
question and I think it all comes back
to he doesn't think that helps him win
football games so at work he's not going
to do it you know Conor the author of
Belichick senior writer espn.com here on
the Rich Eisen show so you spoke to over
300 people for this book I did none of
them Belichick that's correct
okay now
did people who spoke to you giving voice
to Bella checks personality and life and
behind-the-scenes did they check with
Bella check before speaking to you do
you thought some did I think and some
didn't I think some were comfortable
enough in their own skin to just talk
but I do know bill reached out to some
people through either directly or using
an intermediary and asked some people
not to share stories about his life and
and that could be personal I don't know
how he feels about me I intimate
infamously wrote a column in 2000 saying
was a bad hire and I don't know if that
had anything to do with it it might just
be that if he doesn't have control of a
project he doesn't want to lend his
credibility to it and frankly rich he
doesn't owe me anything I realized that
I signed up for the challenge of doing
this and so I I worked around it as best
I could and the way to do that is to
talk to 350 people and and so that's
what I did and I think I wrote the
definitive portrait of him and and I'll
let others be the judge of whether or
not that that indeed was the case all
right let's get into the braiding of it
all here in of all those stories in your
book that I was able to read through
excerpts and otherwise the one quote
that jumped out at me you know
deflategate this and obviously Spygate
that is this quote from an unnamed New
England assistant when Rob Lowe was
drafted said the general feeling among
staff members around the time wasn't
that Bella check system could make Super
Bowl quarterbacks out of all 32 starters
quote but if you gave us any of the top
15 we could do it
the assistant added I don't think the
coaches view Tom as special as everyone
else in football does mr. Kraft thinks
tom is the greatest gift ever but the
coaches don't that made my jaw hit the
floor what what in the world do they
really believe that Brady is a product
of theirs and not their job being
secured potentially by Brady's success
now remember rich deck that quote comes
out of a period of time where Tom's
performance was slipping his arm
strength was diminishing he had won
three not five and had been since 2004
since he had won the big one and in 13
his numbers were coming down there was
an alarming
trend to some degree and that's why they
drafted Garoppolo that night that he
drafted Garoppolo Belichick said he
cited Tom's age and contract status and
he said I'd rather be early than late at
this delicious and he really fired a
warning shot right over his quarterbacks
head and Brady knew that so there was
concern there not only that last year in
spring of 2017 I had a about a 50 55
minute phone conversation with Brady
where we talked about his legacy and I
said to him are you finally willing to
publicly concede that you are the
greatest quarterback of all time that
you have surpassed your idol Joe Montana
and his answer was almost in line with
what that assistant told me he said and
I understand part of this was Brady
humility but I believe I'm a product of
the system I believe there are a lot of
people who if they were in my shoes
would accomplish the same kinds of thing
so I know people have really grabbed
onto that quote but look at it in the
context of the time it referred to that
Tom Brady is not today's Brady who has
five rings another two Super Bowl MVPs
and another League MVP
no but the quote also says that mr.
Kraft thinks tom is the greatest gift
ever but the coaches don't that has
nothing to do with diminishing returns
or abilities he and that has to do with
respect for what he what he did at that
place and that's crazy talk to me and
I'm wondering if that assistant still is
on the on staff well I'm gonna go
further and identifying people that put
their faith and trust in me that I would
protect them and Bill is still very much
the active head coach and Patriots so so
that's why there are some quotes in this
book obviously that needed people needed
some protection on but I will say that I
think the spirit of that quote in
talking to that person was not to knock
down Brady and treat him as if he were
only a top 15 quarterback in the NFL it
wasn't say we do realize he is a great
player but Robert Kraft and your average
fan may think a little bit more highly
of him than we do in terms of his
performance or his ability versus the
significance of the system and not only
Tom Brady's performance but everyone who
passes through that building well and
here's why I really latched onto the two
and I think others might have you know
Konnor the author of bella check here on
the show is that that might be a portal
through which we can look at the 2018
season that if they believed then 2014
that Brady's not the greatest gift and
all has been gone on under the bridge
maybe since then that we could use that
through the portal through which we can
review the current relationship between
Brady and this organization and Bella
check that it's on rockier status than
ever before I think rich it's fair to
say that I think it was inevitable that
there was going to be a confrontation of
sorts that the moment they drafted
Garoppolo to me and talking to people
around brady people know him really well
that it was almost as if drew Henson
showed up again in his life right going
back to Michigan and and obviously he'd
established a lot more in New England
than he did at Michigan but he waited so
long to be the starter Lloyd Carr then
recruits everybody's all-american
everyone fell in love with drew Henson
and Brady had to fight him off which he
did and this was the same kind of thing
now the system the Belichick machine
pushed out every made man in Foxborough
going back to lawyer Milloy through
Logan Mankins and everyone else and it
was designed to push Tom out one year
early rather than one year late and give
the job to Garoppolo he outplayed the
system and forced the Machine to then
churn out Garoppolo and send him to San
Francisco so there was going to be this
confrontation and it happened last year
I think the remarkable thing you've been
around sports a long time too is that it
took 18 years for this to come into
public view this fracture in the
relationship that they held it together
for as long as they did and it's been
entirely a transactional relationship
there's never been any warmth between
the two of them it's been all business
and it's been the greatest partnership
in NFL history but there was bound to be
a meltdown of sorts in that partnership
it happened they barely survived it and
now they try to win ring number six
together and I think they will at some
point I do so how do you think the end
game does wind up I think I don't know
if it's gonna be this year and I do I do
think they have won more in them and I
think the narrative then will be you
people many of
you said that we were done our
relationship was done and we came back
and climbed the mountain one more time I
hope that happened to them all but I'm
there to write that story then it would
be a great one
I could see Belichick at some point
handing it over to Josh McDaniels he
convinced McDaniels to stay and not take
the head job with the Colts and he
certainly is ready for a second chance
Brady and McDonald's have a really good
relationship
so if Belichick wins one more and breaks
the tie with Vince Lombardi and decides
to be the president of the Patriots or
or just to retire I think that's a
feasible scenario but he's a young 66 is
you know he still has a lot of energy he
could coach another five six seven years
I think if he wanted to he still loved
it to death well one would think that
the the way that he was looking at
Garoppolo that he saw another guy that
he could win for 10 15 more years with
right or or somebody that he could coach
for as long as you wanted a coach and
then leave this situation in a very
prosperous way that his legacy would
still grow with him no longer on the
sidelines and he could have like a
Coughlin role in a way even though
Coughlin was forced into that role
because the Giants sent him packing
right so I guess the last question I
have for you on this is everything that
you gleaned about the Belichick Brady
relationship the front office workings
of the New England Patriots all of this
you went back to deflate gate in all the
gates you went through all the gates
okay is how do you think any of what you
learned
relationship-wise manifests itself in
the win-loss column in 2018 and what
happens to see that how does it manifest
itself my I don't think they're 1 & 2
because they had this thing and it
carried into the offseason and Brady
thought of walking away rather than
playing for his head coach one more time
I actually don't think it's related to
their record right now I actually think
they're gonna be three and two and two
weeks but and then as you pointed out
Edelman and Josh Gordon and then I think
things will be okay I do think one thing
the way that Bill coach Tom for 18 years
is part of the reason why they had that
breakdown in their relationship last
year wore Brady out but also the
the reason why they have five rings
because everyone ought roster over time
has seen how unforgiving Belichick has
been in his coaching of Brady and that
has impacted in a positive way the
entire roster they've been held
accountable Brady at the top and
everyone in the middle and at the bottom
to the same degree and that's the reason
why they've won five but it's also the
reason why at war Tom out last year and
again they barely survived it and so
we'll see now if they can get the six I
do think it'll happen in the next two
three years and then I don't think
they'll get the seven but I do they've
got one more run in them all right I
lied I have one last question for your
you know Connor author of Belichick why
do you think so many assistants of Bella
cheques have not had success outside of
New England or outside of his warm
embrace you've got Nick Saban and
obviously there's still some other names
to be written stories to be written
potentially throughout the NFL and save
and you could even say as an outlier
because he's as great as Belichick right
so why do you think that is well
remember rich when Belichick codes
Cleveland and he admitted this I believe
right before that first Super Bowl when
they beat the Rams he tried to be too
much like Parcells and he didn't have
the charisma and personality to pull it
off okay that's why the Cleveland think
one of the reasons why that failed
I think Mangini and McDaniels tried to
be Belichick and they didn't have the
leadership qualities at that point in
time to pull it off they certainly
didn't have the record and I think they
failed for that reason it's it's it's
hard because you need to be yourself but
on the other hand you've learned from
the greatest coach of all time so how do
you not take parts of that with you
right so I just think finding that
balance of being yourself and also like
applying all the lessons you learn from
Belichick and I don't think those two
people in particular accomplish that I
think McDaniel is unlike Mangini now
we'll get man Jeannie had two shots and
failed me I think McDaniels will succeed
the second time around much like
Belichick succeeded after failing to try
to be like Parcells in Cleveland how
about this and I say this with the
utmost of respect because I do think
Bella checks the greatest of all time
that maybe having the greatest gift at
quarterback helps too there's no
question about that but
I will counter that by saying and by the
way I went to the high school or Vince
Lombardi coats in New Jersey Saint
Cecilia's and and so I'm a big Lombardi
guy but but you can't let me if John
Wooden didn't have Lew Alcindor and
Kareem abdul-jabbar Joe Torre didn't
have Mariano and Jeter you could say
that about everybody sure so all right
so the great ones need great players to
prove their greatness so yes you're
right
I'm telling you what I'm telling you man
that that quote from that unnamed
assistant my jaw hit the floor I'm like
you've got and I understand you're
talking about when it was said
circumstances when it was said but
that's still I mean you could have you
could even have said in 2014 Brady had
cemented status as the goat in that way
too rich how about with what Brady said
to me on the phone last year he said no
he didn't say that strongly as the
assistant said it but he said similar
things himself yeah unless you just want
to say that 100% Brady humility but I'll
send you the quote uh-huh and I'll email
it to you and take a look at you got it
Ian congrats again on the book I look
forward to reading it cover-to-cover
thank you
you know Connor at Ian's underscore O
Connor on Twitter Belichick the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience